>> Dan: GETTING DOWNRIGHT
NASTY BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND JOE BIDEN.
BIDEN DOING HIS BEST TO DODGE
AND DEFLECT BETWEEN TRUMP'S
ATTACKS ON HIS SON.
>> I HAVE NEVER DISCUSSED MY
BUSINESS OR MY SONS BUSINESS,
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHAT I HAVE TO
DO MY JOB AND THAT IS IT AND
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THEIR OWN
JUDGMENTS.
IN HE WAS ALREADY ON THE BOARD
AND HE IS A GROWN MAN.
AND IT TURNS OUT HE DID NOT DO A
SINGLE THING WRONG AS EVERYONE'S
INVESTIGATED.
>> Dan: HERE IS BIDEN'S LATEST
LINE OF ATTACK ON TRUMP.
>> TRUMP DOES NOT ONLY WANT TO
GO OUT AND NOT DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT, HE'S ASKING FOR HELP, COME
HELP ME DEFEAT HIM FROM BEING A
NOMINEE.
HE IS AN IDIOT ON TERMS OF
SAYING THAT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THIS, EVERYBODY
KNOWS IT.
NOBODY DOUBTS IT.
>> Dan: I'LL GO TO YOU FIRST
HERE BECAUSE I NEED A LITTLE
COMIC RELIEF ON THIS.
HE IS THE POINT MAN FOR THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IN UKRAINE.
WHILE THERE DISCUSSING NATURAL
GAS, NO SKILLS WHATSOEVER, A
BUCK 20, 80,000 A MONTH BUT NO
CONFLICT OF INTEREST AT ALL ON
THIS ONE.
IF >> Greg: BECAUSE OF THE
OCCUPATION WHERE INCOMPETENCE IS
NOT AN OBSTACLE.
WHAT'S REALLY LOVELY ABOUT THIS
IS WATCHING JOE GET SUCKED INTO
THE EXHAUST OF THE IMPEACHMENT
MACHINE.
HE DIDN'T SEE THIS COMING, HIS
TEAM WAS UP AT BAT AND HE GOT
HIT BY THE FOUL BALL AND THEN
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY'RE RUNNING TO
THAT, THEY ARE DATING AND NOT
GOING TO MARRY.
HE IS THE UMBRELLA YOU BORROW
ENOUGH/STORM, NOT YOUR FIRST
CHOICE BUT THERE FOR THE MOMENT.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS LOOKING
AT 2024.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT IMPEACHMENT
TO GET AROUND 2020.
>> Dan: THIS IS AN OBVIOUS
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
>> Dana: HE KIND OF ALREADY
HAS BECAUSE HE SAID IF HE WERE
TO BECOME PRESIDENT THAT HE
WOULD NOT ALLOW SUCH THINGS TO
HAPPEN.
SO IT MAKES YOU THINK IF IT
WOULD BE BAD IN THE FUTURE, WAS
IT NOT BAD IN THE PAST AND WE
KNOW THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT IT AND SAID
SOMETHING TO HIM BUT THEY DIDN'T
CARE ENOUGH.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THEY'VE
ALLOWED PRESIDENT TRUMP TO BE
THE ONE TO DIRTY UP BIDEN.
OTHER DEMOCRATS ARE NOT GOING
AFTER HIM AND MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE
THEY THINK IS NOT GOING TO BE
THE NOMINEE, IT'S REALLY HARD TO
SAY.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME BIDEN HAS
DONE AN INTERVIEW IN A LONG TIME
AND HE WAS TRYING TO DRIVE NEWS,
NOT JUST REACT TO THINGS LIKE
BAD FUND-RAISING OR A GAP OR A
SCREWUP.
IF HE DOESN'T BECOME THE
NOMINEE, THE REPUBLICANS GOT
SOMETHING FROM THAT INTERVIEW IT
WOULD BE DRIVING HOME IN THE
2020 ELECTION.
HE SAID MEDICARE FOR ALL WILL
REQUIRE A TAX INCREASE ON THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
IF JOE BIDEN DOESN'T BECOME THE
NOMINEE AND SOMEONE THAT'S
RUNNING IS FOR MEDICARE FOR ALL,
YOU CAN BET THAT WILL BE ON
EVERY TV SCREEN AND EVERY RADIO
AND EVERY FACEBOOK POST FROM
HERE UNTIL ELECTION DAY.
>> THAT'S WHY WE ARE STUCK WITH
JOE BIDEN AS DEMOCRATS AND I
WISH THAT WE WEREN'T, HE IS LIKE
A DOG WITH FLEAS AND A LITTLE
BIT MORE LIKE AN ARRANGED
MARRIAGE, SOMEONE WE ARE STUCK
WITH MORE THAN SOMEONE WE ARE
DATING.
BUT HE'S DOING DECENT IN THE
POLLS WITH THE TYPE OF PEOPLE
THAT WE NEED IN ORDER TO WIN IN
PLACES LIKE WISCONSIN AND OHIO.
>> Jesse: I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE
HE CALLED SOMEONE ELSE AN IDIOT.
IF THAT'S HIS REPUTATION BUT IT
SHOWS NOW HE HAS BEING SUCKED
INTO THE SCHOOLYARD BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHERE TRUMP WANTS HIM
BECAUSE HE IS THE KING OF THE
SCHOOLYARD AND THE WHOLE APPEAL
AS I'M GOING TO RESTORE DECENCY
TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND NOW
NAME-CALLING WITH THE PRESIDENT,
NOT A GOOD LOOK.
AND HE LIES ABOUT HIS SON, HE
WAS APPOINTED POINTS FOR
UKRAINE, THEN HIS SON GOT THE
JOB, NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND
AND LET HIM GET OUT OF THE WAY
WITH THAT AND ALSO, YOU ARE
SAYING YOUR DEFENSE ON THAT IS
IGNORANCE, I DON'T WANT TO KNOW
IF MY FAMILY IS FOR SALE, I
DON'T WANT TO KNOW MY BROTHER
GOT A $1.5 BILLION CONTRACT TO
BUILD A HOUSE IN IRAQ WITH NO
EXPERIENCE.